Our story begins one day in November of 1902. Just a few months prior, President Theodore Roosevelt had become the first president to make a public appearance in a car. And now, he was off on a new adventure, this one taking him to a small town in Mississippi called Smeads. And he's gone down to Smeads to do a hunt, a bear hunt. That's journalist John Muellen. And he's there for a few days without seeing a single bear. and then his hunting party happens to spot one, and it runs into a kind of a weedy thicket.
我们的故事始于 1902 年 11 的某一天。就在几个月前，西奥多·罗斯福总统刚刚成为第一位坐汽车公开露面的总统。现在，他又踏上了一场新的冒险，这次要去的是密西西比州一个叫斯米兹的小镇。他去斯米兹是为了狩猎，猎熊。这是记者约翰·穆伦说的。他在那里待了好几天，连一只熊的影子都没见着；接着，他的狩猎队碰巧发现了一只熊，它跑进了一片杂草丛生的灌木丛中。
It's a good move. The hunters can't really get to the bear. But Roosevelt's guide says, hang on, you just stay right here, and I'll flush it out, and you can kill it. Roosevelt gets a little bored, though, and he goes back to have lunch. So when the hunting guide finally flushes the bear out,
这招不错。猎人们根本靠近不了那只熊。但罗斯福的向导说，等等，你就在这儿待着，我把它赶出来，然后你就能干掉它。不过罗斯福觉得有点无聊，就回去吃午饭了。所以，当狩猎向导终于把熊赶出来时，
Roosevelt is nowhere to be seen. So his guide jumps off his horse, waxed the bear on the top of the head, with the end of his rifle and then ties it to a tree, and then starts calling the president back over so that he can do the honors. When the president arrives and sees the bear, let's just say he was far from impressed. He takes a look at this thing and it just looks pitiable, dazed, kind of semi-conscious, looks pretty mangy, malnourished and about half of its normal weight.
罗斯福却不见踪影。于是他的向导从马背上跳下来，用步枪托狠狠砸了一下熊的脑袋，把它绑在一棵树上，然后开始叫总统回来，好让他来完成这最后一步。当总统赶到并看到这只熊时，只能说他一点也高兴不起来。他看了一眼这个家伙，它看起来太可怜了，神情恍惚、半昏迷状态，毛发十分凌乱、营养不良，只有正常体重的一半左右。
And so he takes pity on it and he says, you know, it's against my code as a sportsman to shoot this pathetic thing, and he refuses. This moment in which he refuses to shoot the bear, it's memorialized a few days later in a cartoon in a newspaper in Washington, D.C. The cartoon is captioned, drawing the line in Mississippi. And when you look at this cartoon, you see the president there with his arm out, kind of sparing the bear's life, and he's holding his rifle. And the bear is there just watching Roosevelt, wondering, you know, what's going to happen
于是他起了恻隐之心，说道，你知道的，向这只可怜的家伙开枪违背了我作为一个运动员的准则，他拒绝了。他拒绝向熊开枪的这一幕，几天后被纪念在华盛顿特区一家报纸的漫画中。这幅漫画的标题是《在密西西比划清界限》。当你看着这幅漫画时，你会看到总统伸出胳膊，算是饶了这只熊一命，他手里拿着步枪。而那只熊就站在那里看着罗斯福，心里琢磨着，你知道的，接下来会发生什么
to it. He's got its fate in his hands. This bear looks really vulnerable and cute. Its eyes are huge. He's got a big round head. And it wouldn't necessarily be familiar to you at the time in 1902, but now we understand what this thing is right away. It's a teddy bear. After this cartoon runs, a toy manufacturer turns the bear from that cartoon into a stuffed animal and start selling teddy's bear all over the United States. And it becomes a huge hit. Teddy's Bear for Theodore Roosevelt, an object that would become so ubiquitous it would take on a life of its own outside of its namesake president. In fact, I bet you or your kid have one somewhere in your house right now. But before we get ahead of ourselves, the teddy bear is not our object
它将面临怎样的命运。它的命运掌握在他手中。这只熊看起来真的很脆弱、很可爱。它的眼睛大大的。它有一个圆乎乎的大脑袋。在1902年那个时候，你可能对它并不熟悉，但现在我们立刻就能明白这是个什么东西。这是一只泰迪熊。这幅漫画发表后，一家玩具制造商把漫画里的熊变成了一个毛绒玩具，并开始在美国各地销售“泰迪熊”。它大获成功。“泰迪熊”因西奥多·罗斯福而得名，这个物件变得如此无处不在，以至于在它的同名总统之外拥有了属于自己的生命。事实上，我敢打赌你或你的孩子现在家里某处就有一个。不过在我们操之过急之前，泰迪熊并不是我们这一期的主角。
for this episode. Now, our object comes out of what happens next, because what is first about this story is that the lesson that the toy manufacturers take from this is that maybe this model can be repeated. Maybe every president from here on out will have a viral stuffed animal named after them. Yeah, so they're thinking, well, Roosevelt's going to leave office in 1909. We need the next president's version of the teddy bear. Now, the next president was William Howard Taft, not nearly as charismatic of a fellow as Teddy Roosevelt. But, you know, the profit motive is strong. We've got to find something to be a mascot for his presidency. And they land on something a little suspect in retrospect.
现在，我们的主角源于接下来发生的事情，因为这个故事开创先河的地方在于，玩具制造商从这件事中得到的教训是，也许这种模式可以复制。也许从今以后，每一位总统都会有一个以他们名字命名的病毒式传播的毛绒玩具。是的，所以他们在想，罗斯福将在 1909 年卸任。我们需要下一任总统版本的泰迪熊。现在，下一任总统是威廉·霍华德·塔夫茨，他可远没有西奥多·罗斯福那么有个人魅力。但是，你知道的，追逐利润的动力很强劲。我们得找点什么来作为他总统任期的吉祥物。事后回想起来，他们看中的是一个有点可疑的东西。
It's not a bear. It's a possum. And they market it as the Billy Possum. There's a reason why you have not heard of the Billy Possum. And there's a reason why there's no Billy Possum next to your sleeping child in the other room. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States and 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. We in America, land of the bald eagle, have always turned animals into symbols.
它不是熊。它是一只负鼠。他们将其作为“比利负鼠”进行营销。你没有听说过“比利负鼠”是有原因的。你隔壁房间里熟睡的孩子旁边没有“比利负鼠”也是有原因的。这里是 99% Invisible 和 BBC 工作室，为您讲述美国历史与 100 件物品的故事。我是罗曼·马斯。我们美国人，作为白头海雕的国度，一直把动物变成象征。
They represent what we're afraid of, what we love, what we think deserves to survive. Those stories are some of the most powerful tools we have for protecting the natural world. Today, the story of the Billy Possum. and how our fickle feelings about animals have shaped the history and perhaps the future of our relationship with the natural world. Before we meet the Billy Possum and Full, let's go back to the moment his infinitely more successful cousin, the teddy bear, was first introduced. When that cartoon showing Roosevelt refusing to shoot the cute little bear was published, it was not how people were used to seeing bears or how most people thought about them. Because back in the early 1900s, we did not see bears as cute. You know, bears were monsters.
它们代表着我们害怕的东西、我们所爱的东西、我们认为值得生存的东西。这些故事是我们保护自然世界最有力的工具之一。今天，我们要讲述比利负鼠的故事，以及我们对动物变幻莫测的情感是如何塑造了我们与自然世界的关系的历史，或许还有未来。在我们全面了解比利负鼠之前，让我们回到它的那位名气大得多的表亲——泰迪熊——首次亮相的那一刻。当那幅展示罗斯福拒绝射杀可爱小熊的漫画发表时，这并不是人们习惯看到的熊的模样，也不是大多数人对它们的看法。因为早在 20 世纪初，我们并不觉得熊很可爱。你知道的，熊是怪物。
Bears were a shorthand for everything that was dangerous and unruly about nature, about the Western frontier. This was part of an outlook in the United States that anything big and wild was basically a threat to us and a threat to our ability to take over the landscape. Yeah. And we didn't just treat it as a threat. Like this was an active response to the federal government, that we were going to eradicate. bear so that people could live in the West? Yes, we were absolutely at war with bears. There was a department of the federal government
熊是自然界中所有危险和桀骜不驯的事物、西部边境的一切的代名词。这是美国人的一种观点的一部分，即任何庞大而野生的东西基本上都是对我们的威胁，是对我们接管这片土地的能力的威胁。是的。而且我们不仅仅把它当作一种威胁。就像这是对联邦政府的一种积极回应，我们要消灭熊，好让人们能在西部生活？是的，我们绝对是在与熊开战。联邦政府有一个部门
called the Bureau for Biological Survey. One of its primary jobs was just shooting and trapping and killing animals. We had sorted nature into sort of the desirable and undesirable ones, and we were letting all the undesirable ones really have it. Coyotes, wolves, mountain lions. It's also a cultural outlook.
叫做生物调查局。它的主要工作之一就是射杀、设陷阱和屠杀动物。我们把自然分成了所谓的可取和不可取的东西，我们真的在对所有不可取的东西大开杀戒。郊狼、狼、美洲狮。这也是一种文化观点。
You see this reflected in a lot of fiction of the time, especially fiction for kids. Ladies' Home Journal magazine published a story in 1900 about a boy named Balzer, who was described as, quote, the happiest boy in Indiana because he owned a rifle and enough ammunition to kill every creature
你会在当时的许多小说中看到这种反映，尤其是写给孩子的小说。《女士家庭杂志》于 1900 年发表了一篇关于一个名叫巴尔泽的男孩的故事，他被描述为，引述一下，“印第安纳州最快乐的男孩，因为他拥有一支步枪和足够的弹药，可以杀死方圆五英里内的所有生物”。
within five miles. And in this story, Balzer, he kills a bearer, but he gets bitten by the bear in the process. And so it all culminates in this kind of feel-good ending when Balzer and his dad tracked down the bear's mate and then shoot her in revenge. And how successful were we at this time period of taking out the bears? Very successful.
在这篇故事里，巴尔泽杀了一只熊，但在过程中被熊咬了。所以这一切最终以一个大团圆结局收场，巴尔泽和他的爸爸追踪到那只熊的伴侣，然后开枪打死它以进行报复。在这一时期，我们在消灭熊方面有多成功？非常成功。
If you want to call that success. Yeah, this is an era in which a lot of what we call, you know, megafauna of the United States is being driven, you know, either out of its territory or just extinct. The grizzly bear was a huge target of these efforts. And it was about to be extirpated from 95% of its original range. in the continental U.S.? The eradication of the grizzly bear
如果你想把那叫做成功的话。是的，这是一个我们所说的美国巨型动物群中的很多物种，要么被驱逐出它们的领地，要么直接灭绝的时代。灰熊是这些行动的巨大目标。它险些在美国本土大陆的原有栖息地中被灭绝 95%？灰熊的根除
coincided with a big shift in America. For the first time in our history, a majority of Americans were living in cities, far from nature, far from the threat of bears. And so, as more and more bears disappeared from the landscape, they started showing up differently in our imaginations and in the pages of children's books.
恰逢美国的一个重大转变。在我们历史上第一次，大多数美国人居住在城市里，远离自然，远离熊的威胁。因此，随着越来越多的熊从大自然中消失，它们开始以不同的方式出现在我们的想象中和儿童书的字里行间。
There was an extremely famous writer at the time named Ernest Thompson-Syton, who was leading... a movement in fiction, especially stories that were read by a lot of American children, where he was writing stories with protagonists who were bears and other animals, exactly the same kind of species that the government was busy exterminating. One of his most famous books was called The Biography of a Grizzly, and it centers on a cub named Wob, who, at the beginning of the book,
当时有一位极其著名的作家叫欧内斯特·汤普森·西顿，他领导着一场文学运动，特别是那些被许多美国儿童阅读的故事，他创作的故事以熊和其他动物为主角，而这些动物恰恰是政府正忙于消灭的同类物种。他最著名的书之一叫《灰熊自传》，书中以一只名叫沃布的小熊为中心，在书的开头，
has to watch his mother and his siblings be shot dead by a rancher. And the rest of the book is just this poor cub, wandering through a wilderness where every threat to him is not a wild threat, but a man-made threat. So he's dodging traps and other people with guns. Even the scent of man is said to, you know, be unsettling to him. So now these grizzlies that were once seen as ferocious competitors on the landscape, you know, things to fear, they're now fearing us. And what Seton's getting at is something that you see across the culture.
它不得不眼睁睁看着母亲和兄弟姐妹被牧场主开枪打死。书的剩余部分就是这只可怜的小熊，在荒野中游荡，它面临的每一个威胁都不是野生威胁，而是人造威胁。所以它在躲避陷阱和拿着枪的人。甚至连人的气味都被认为会让他感到不安。所以现在，这些曾经被视为风景线上凶猛竞争对手的灰熊，你知道的，令人恐惧的东西，现在它们开始害怕我们了。而西顿想要表达的是一种你在整个文化中都能看到的东西。
People are really starting to feel conflicted about. all the killing going on. We hated the bear and we feared the bear, but we also suddenly sort of wanted to give the bear a hug. So this is the ideological war that is going on as the teddy bear arrives at our shores. What happens after that political cartoon and the teddy bear takes off the way it does? What happens when the teddy bear hits the market? It kickstarts this whole craze of teddy bears, where within a few years, this German company, Steif, is said to be exporting a million bears a year. Suddenly, it's to the extent that there are newspaper editorials worrying about children playing with bears instead of dolls. They're displacing human dolls,
人们真的开始对正在发生的所有杀戮感到矛盾。我们讨厌熊，我们也害怕熊，但突然之间我们又有点想给熊一个拥抱。所以，这就是泰迪熊登陆我们海岸时正在进行的思想战争。那幅政治漫画和泰迪熊大获成功之后发生了什么？当泰迪熊进入市场时会发生什么？它引发了一股泰迪熊热潮，几年之内，据说德国公司 Steif 每年出口一百万只熊。突然之间，报纸社论甚至开始担心孩子们玩熊而不是玩娃娃。它们正在取代人类的娃娃，
and what could this mean? You can buy clothing for your bear. You can buy winter coats for your bear, which is astonishing, because this, I sort of think of this as the moment that the evolutionary trajectory of teddy bears and regular bear splits, that your teddy bear now won't be warm unless it has a winter coat. This is the point in our story where people know that Theodore Roosevelt is not going to be president that much longer. And they need to figure out what to do next. Taff gets elected. He's sort of Teddy Roosevelt's handpicked successor. And they want a new cuddly play thing to sort of mark his presidency.
这意味着什么？你可以为你的熊买衣服。你可以为你的熊买冬衣，这太惊人了，因为这，我有点把这看作是泰迪熊和普通熊的进化轨迹分道扬镳的时刻，你的泰迪熊现在如果不穿冬衣就不会保暖。这就是我们故事中的那个时间点，人们知道西奥多·罗斯福不会再当很久的总统了。他们需要弄清楚下一步该做什么。塔夫茨当选了。他可以说是西奥多·罗斯福钦点的继承人。他们想要一个新的可爱玩物来标志他的总统任期。
So let's talk about the Billy Possum story. How did they come to deciding on a possum as the thing that would represent William Howard Taft? Right. So once again, we're in the South. We're in Atlanta. So Taft is going to be inaugurated. He's doing a tour of the South. And he's the guest of honor at a banquet in Atlanta for the Atlanta Chamber of Commerce. And they're pulling out all the stops. And they serve him this very particular southern delicacy, you know, really seen as an authentic piece of the South. And it's called possum and taters. What we have is an opossum roasted hole, head on, tail still hanging off it, like a meaty noodle. And it's on a platter surrounded by sweet potatoes. And in many cases, it would be served with a small sweet potato crammed into the opossum's mouth. And how many teeth does an opossum have, Roman?
所以让我们来谈谈比利负鼠的故事。他们是怎么决定用负鼠作为代表威廉·霍华德·塔夫茨的标志的？对的。所以我们再次来到了南方。我们在亚特兰大。所以塔夫茨即将就职。他正在南方巡回访问。他是亚特兰大商会在亚特兰大举行的一场宴会上的特邀贵宾。他们拿出了所有的绝招。他们给他端上了一道非常特别的南方美食，你知道的，这真被视为南方正宗的美食。它叫负鼠烤山芋。我们看到的是一只整只烤好的负鼠，头还在，尾巴还挂着，就像一根肉面条。它放在一个周围环绕着红薯的大拼盘上。在许多情况下，它上菜时嘴里还会塞着一个小红薯。罗曼，负鼠有多少颗牙齿？
Do you remember? I have no. 50 teeth. So jammed in its 50 teeth, which is just a phenomenally disgusting number of teeth, is a small sweet potato. This thing is rolled out at the middle of the banquet. The one they put on Taft's table weighs 18 pounds. He eats it. After he's done, the band starts playing, and a group of Taft supporters makes a big ceremony of giving him a surprise gift.
你还记得吗？我不知道。50 颗牙齿。所以卡在它的 50 颗牙齿里的——这是一个极其恶心的牙齿数量——是一个小红薯。这个东西在宴会中央被推了出来。放在塔夫茨桌上的那只重达 18 磅。他把它吃掉了。他吃完后，乐队开始演奏，一群塔夫茨的支持者举行了一个盛大的仪式，送给他一份惊喜礼物，
and it's a small stuffed a possum toy very realistic with those kind of creepy, beady eyes, the naked ears, the tail, they hand this thing over
是一个小型毛绒负鼠玩具，非常逼真，有着那种令人毛骨悚然的、小小的豆粒般的眼睛，光秃秃的耳朵，尾巴，他们把这个东西交了过来，
with great pomp. This is the icon of his presidency. This is it. This is the Billy Possum. Billy Possum. As in William Howard Tafts, possum. I mean,
带着极大的盛况。这就是他总统任期的标志。就是这个。这就是比利负鼠。比利负鼠。就像威廉·霍华德·塔夫茨的负鼠。我的意思是，
they had this whole manufacturing apparatus and marketing machine ready for this moment to make this work. Yeah, this is the launch. This is the activation. This is the Billy Possum activation, but all the groundwork has been laid. I read news reports about how within 24 hours this company called the Georgia Billy Possum Company, which was already set up and ready to go. Within 24 hours of the banquet, they're already brokering deals to distribute the toys all over the country. The LA Times covering this, wrote, the teddy bear has been relegated to a seat in the rear, and for four years, possibly eight, the children of the United States will play with Billy Possums. So I actually found an
他们为了这个时刻准备了整套制造机构和营销机器来让这件事成功。是的，这是发布。这是激活。这就是比利负鼠激活，但所有的基础工作都已经做好了。我读到过新闻报道，在 24 小时内，这家名为佐治亚比利负鼠公司的公司（该公司已经成立并准备就绪）在宴会结束后的 24 小时内，他们已经在安排将玩具分销到全国各地的交易了。《洛杉矶通讯》对此进行了报道，写道：“泰迪熊已经被降级到后排座位，在四年里，可能八年里，美国的孩子们将和比利负鼠玩耍。”所以我实际上在布鲁克林的一家玩具店找到了一则广告，里面有一个促销活动，孩子们可以进去看一个真正的负鼠在笼子里，这样他们就会更熟悉这个东西，它将成为他们接下来四年（可能八年）的可爱伙伴。广告上写着：“不要让别人说布鲁克林有任何男人、女人或孩子没有见过那只可爱的小动物，它的名字今天在世界各地被提及的次数比任何其他动物都要多。”所以，是的，对比利负鼠非常看好。不仅是玩具本身，还有各种各样的其他相关商品，对吧？商品化。是的，有类似的比利负鼠周边商品来帮助这股热潮传播得更广。有明信片，有咖啡伴侣奶油的图片，塔夫茨的支持者
advertisement for a toy store in Brooklyn that had a promotion where kids could come in and see a actual a possum in a cage so that they would just get more familiar with this thing that was going to be their cuddly pal for the next four years, possibly eight. And the ad read, do not let it be said that any man woman or child in Brooklyn has not seen the cute little animal whose name is mentioned more in all parts of the world today than any other. So yeah, very bullish on Billy Possums. And not just the toys themselves, but there's all kinds of other merchandise associated, right? Merchandising. Yeah, there's like attendant Billy Possum merchandise to help make the craze go even wider. There was postcards, there was pictures for cream for coffee time, Taft supporters.
在他的就职典礼上佩戴了比利负鼠徽章。然后，当塔夫茨在全国各地巡回演出时，人们实际上在火车站和公开露面时迎接他，并把真正的负鼠像一束鲜花一样交给他。有一个时刻，短暂的时刻，当它成为这个男人的某种标志。正如你所提到的，这个时刻是短暂的。比利负鼠怎么了？回答你的问题，比利负鼠几乎什么都没发生。你知道的，据我所能了解到的，仅仅几个月后，就没有任何地方提到它了。每个人都不再关心它，销量暴跌。请记住，这一切都始于 1909 年 1 月。这意味着比利负鼠甚至没能撑到圣诞节。它甚至没有看到一个
wore Billy Possum pins at his inauguration. And then as Taft is touring around the country, people are actually meeting him at railroad stations and appearances and handing over actual possums like bouquets of flowers. There's a moment, a brief moment, when it's sort of an icon of the man. And as you mentioned, this moment is brief. What happens to the Billy Possum? Almost nothing happens with the Billy Possum to answer your question. You know, from what I could tell it's really just only a matter of months before there's no mention of it anywhere. Everyone stops caring about it, sales, tank. And remember that this all started in January of 1909. So that means the Billy Possum didn't even make it to Christmas. It didn't even get to see a
圣诞季，这对于一个玩具来说算是一种特殊的悲剧。所以，我的意思是，这可能有一些显而易见的答案，但我认为对于为什么泰迪熊大行其道而比利负鼠没有，可能会有一些不太显而易见的答案，你对此有什么看法？是的，显而易见的答案是，你知道的，负鼠真的很丑。要想让它看起来舒适可爱，或者像一个你想照顾的东西，我觉得这真的是一个很大的延伸。是的，嗯，我只是觉得这个事实是无可回避的。不过更有趣的是，我也觉得负鼠缺少一个能与美国人产生共鸣的故事，哪怕只是潜意识里的共鸣。
Christmas season, which is sort of a special tragedy for a toy. So, I mean, there might be some obvious answer to this, but I think there might be some non-obvious answers as to why the teddy bears took off and the billy possums didn't what are your thoughts on that yeah well the obvious answer is that you know possums are really ugly it's a really long stretch i think to make one seem uh snugly and adorable or like something you want to take care of yeah um i just don't think there's any any getting around that fact more interestingly though I also think that the possum lacked a story that had any resonance with Americans, even just subconsciously.
我的意思是，当你仔细想想，在人类进化的整个历史中，熊一直是这个标志，你知道的，它是可怕的，它独立于我们，这就是让它如此令人印象深刻的原因。它过着平行的一生，作为对我们的威胁，作为我们的竞争对手，在某些方面比我们更优越、更强大。现在，在泰迪熊的时代，我们已经把这个生物击退到了这样一种程度，以至于它任由我们摆布，它的生存将取决于我们。我认为这会激起一些非常复杂的情感，
I mean, when you think about it for all of humans' evolutionary history, the bear was this icon, you know, it was fearsome, it was independent from us, and that's what made it so impressive. It was living a parallel life as a menace to us, as a competitor to us, in some ways are superior, more powerful than us. And now, at the time of the teddy bear, we've beaten that creature back to such a degree that it is at our mercy, that its survival is going to be dependent on us. And I think that stirs up some really complicated emotions,
你知道的，既对自然界的未来感到担忧，也对我们在其中的地位感到担忧，这种新地位使我们对一切都拥有了一种残酷的统治权。我认为这让许多人感到非常不安。这种振荡发生在将动物妖魔化、消灭它，然后突然对这只动物产生共鸣，将其视为无助的弱者，并在我们心中重塑其形象，将其视为需要我们帮助的无辜可爱之物的过程之间。你可以说，这就是约翰的“泰迪熊与比利负鼠理论”，我们爱这只熊的原因，正是因为我们与它之间存在着这种引人入胜的复杂关系。我们害怕熊。我们丑化熊。我们杀死了熊，然后我们对杀死熊感到非常内疚，以至于现在我们
you know, both worries about the future of nature, but also worries about our place in it, this new place where we really have a kind of brutal dominion over everything. I think that's really unsettling for a lot of people. There's this oscillation that happens between demonizing an animal and then eradicating it and then suddenly empathizing with that animal as a kind of helpless underdog and rewriting its reputation in our minds as something innocent and sweet that needs our help. This, you could say, is John's Teddy Bear versus Billy Possum theory, that the reason we love the bear is because of this compelling complex relationship we have with it. We feared the bear. We vilified the bear. We killed the bear and then we felt so bad about killing the bear that now we
想要拯救它。而负鼠真的完全没有那种共鸣。很难对负鼠产生任何感觉，无论是好是坏。它缺乏任何的情感分量。关于塔夫茨的故事是，有人给他端上一只死负鼠，他把它吃掉了。而且他真的很喜欢。你知道的，他吃了好几份，然后一直吃个不停，他桌上的一位医生实际上递给他一张便条，说你也许应该吃慢一点。第二天，塔夫茨还在向记者吹嘘这件事。他说，嗯，我喜欢负鼠。我昨晚吃得很丰盛，它一点也没有打扰我的消化或睡眠。是的，他简直把它们全消灭了。所以我们列出了灭绝动物与对它们产生共鸣之间的这种振荡模式。这种模式在整个 20 世纪不断重复，在那段
wanted to save it. Whereas the possum really had none of that resonance. It was hard to feel anything for the opossum, good or bad. It was lacking of any kind of emotional import. The story with Taft was someone served him a dead opossum and he ate it. And he really loved it too. You know, he had a few helpings and then he just kept going and a doctor at his table actually passed him a note saying maybe you should slow down. And the next day he was, Taft was bragging to reporters about it. He said, well, I like possum. I ate very heartily of it last night, and it did not disturb in the slightest my digestion or my sleep. Yeah, he just obliterated it. So we laid out this pattern of oscillation between exterminating animals and then empathizing with them. That pattern repeats throughout the 20th century, and during that
时间里，动物开始成为关于环境斗争的有用象征。以白头海雕为例。它因过度捕猎和使用杀虫剂 DDT 而险些灭绝，然后人们意识到它即将灭绝，并把它变成了反对 DDT 的大型运动的形象代言人，一场巨大且成功的运动。斑点猫鹰和伐木业也发生了同样的事情。但所有这些环境斗争与21世纪初地球面临的生存威胁相比，简直不值一提。你知道，有趣的是，在2005年，我记得我当时在伯克利读
time, animals start to become useful symbols for fights about the environment. Take the bald eagle. It was nearly wiped out from overhunting and the use of the pesticide DDT, and then people clocked that it was going extinct and turned it into the face of a big campaign against DDT, a big, successful campaign. The same thing happened with the spotted owl and the logging industry. But all of those environmental fights were nothing compared to the existential threat that the planet was facing in the early 2000s. You know, it's interesting in 2005, I remember being in great. graduate school at Berkeley and watching with a class the aftermath of Katrina,
研究生，和全班同学一起观看卡特里娜飓风过后余波，
Hurricane Katrina, and seeing New Orleans flooded and realizing for the first time that there was a sort of general understanding that like, oh, you know, this has to do with climate change. As the evidence for climate change started to stack up, climate activists and attorneys were trying to get the government to do something about it. And so what happens in the early 2000s is you have a group of environmental attorneys who have been struggling for years to try to get the George W. Bush administration to act on climate change or even just to acknowledge the science around greenhouse gases. But so far, all of their attempts had largely failed. What could they do to make the issue urgent enough to get the public outraged and the government to act? They needed some kind of emotional
飓风卡特里娜，看到新奥尔良被洪水淹没，并第一次意识到有一种普遍的共识，即“哦，你知道的，这与气候变化有关”。随着气候变化证据的不断堆积，气候活动人士和律师一直在试图让政府采取行动。因此，在 2000 年代初发生的事情是，有一群环境律师多年来一直在挣扎，试图让乔治·W·布什政府对气候变化采取行动，或者甚至只是承认围绕温室气体的科学。但到目前为止，他们的所有尝试大多都失败了。他们能做些什么来让这个问题变得足够紧迫，从而激起公众的愤怒并促使政府采取行动？他们需要某种情感上的
trigger, something that was going to not just make climate change feel, real and urgent and an intellectual way, but that would cut through the kind of busyness of people's lives and make them care. An emotional trigger, something people could care about, something like an animal. You had environmental attorneys who were just in the trenches suing the administration, and one of these groups of Center for Biological Diversity hit upon this pretty ingenious idea, and that was to get a species listed as endangered under the... the U.S. Endangered Species Act, specifically because of the threat of climate change to its survival.
触发点，某种不仅能以一种理智的方式让气候变化感觉真实和紧迫，而且能穿透人们生活的繁忙并让他们真正关心的事情。一个情感触发点，人们可以关心的事情，比如动物。你有一些身处一线、起诉政府的环境律师，其中一个名为“生物多样性中心”的组织想出了一个非常巧妙的主意，那就是根据美国《濒危物种法案》，
Here's why the plan is ingenious. Because by law, if a species is listed as endangered, then the government is legally bound to look at what is threatening its survival. They could put that science in front of the administration. They would essentially force its hand to do what it had not wanted to do in other contexts, which was to affirm the validity of climate change. No more dodging or dismissing. But to make this work, the activists feel like they have to really find the perfect animal. So basically, they start a casting process. And a good candidate on that front is going to be two things. It's going to have a lot of solid science backing it up to say that, yes, this thing will go extinct because of climate change. And it's going to be something that ordinary people care about.
将一个物种列为濒危物种，其具体原因就是气候变化对其生存构成了威胁。这就是这个计划巧妙的原因。因为根据法律，如果一个物种被列为濒危物种，那么政府在法律上有义务调查是什么在威胁它的生存。他们可以把这些科学证据摆在政府面前。这基本上会迫使其采取它在其他情况下一直不愿意做的事情，那就是确认气候变化的有效性。不再闪烁其词或不予理睬。但为了让这个计划发挥作用，活动人士觉得他们必须真正找到完美的动物。所以基本上，他们开始了一个选角过程。而在这方面一个好的候选者需要具备两点。它将有很多坚实的科学支持，证明是的，这个东西会因为气候变化而灭绝。而且它将是普通人关心的事情。
Because if there isn't the public interests, no matter how good the science is, the administration did have ways of kind of shunting that animal off into a kind of bureaucratic abyss and not having to deal with it. In fact, hundreds and hundreds of species were sitting in a backlog waiting to be looked at by the government, species that the public had never even heard of. The Neosho Mucket Muscle and the Slabside Purley muscle, the band rumped storm petrol, the spotless crake, the relic leopard frog, we've got a whole list of cave beetles, the icebox cave beetle, Fowler's Cave Beetle, Fire Cave Beetle, the Tatum Cave Beetle. And at the time in 2013, when I was looking into this, at least 24 different species had actually gone extinct while they were waiting around on the candidate list.
因为如果没有公众的兴趣，无论科学多么好，政府确实有办法把这种动物抛到一个官僚主义的深渊里，而不必去处理它。事实上，成百上千个物种正积压着等待政府审查，这些物种是公众甚至从未听说过的。尼欧舍厚壳蚌和厚侧珍珠蚌、斑臀海燕、无斑秧鸡、遗迹豹蛙，我们有一整串洞穴甲虫清单：冰盒洞穴甲虫、福勒洞穴甲虫、火洞穴甲虫、塔特姆洞穴甲虫。而在2013年我调查这件事的时候，至少有24个不同的物种在候选名单上苦苦等待时实际上已经灭绝了。
Wow. And essentially, no one cared about them. These things could just sort of pass into Olivia and unnoticed, even though they had been deemed worthy of protection. And that's what the Center for Biological Diversity was trying to avoid. That's why they needed the public behind them so that, whatever they petition the government for, wouldn't just slip away silently. So they needed a good candidate, but they also needed one whose survival was really linked to climate change. And this was harder than you might think,
哇。基本上，没有人关心它们。这些东西就这样默默无闻地进入了遗忘的深渊，尽管它们已经被认为值得保护。这就是生物多样性中心试图避免的事情。这就是为什么他们需要公众的支持，这样无论他们向政府请愿什么，都不会悄无声息地溜走。所以他们需要一个好的候选者，但他们也需要一个其生存确实与气候变化息息相关的候选者。这比你想象的要难，
because remember, this is the early 2000s, and we're just starting to get a grasp on climate change, and there are very few actual studies that have been done about its impact on specific species. So they went looking for species, and a lot of the candidates they came up with were way more Billy Possum. than teddy bear.
因为记住，这是 2000 年代初，我们才刚刚开始了解气候变化，而且针对其对特定物种影响的实际研究非常少。因此，他们开始寻找物种，他们想出的许多候选者更像是比利负鼠而不是泰迪熊。
The first animal that the Center for Biological Diversity looked at was called the Glacier Bay Wolf Spider. Okay, so it's a spider. It's disgusting. Second of all, it turns out there was some uncertainty about whether it was even its own species. So that one gets tossed out. Next, they have this kind of small speckled seabird in Alaska called the Kitlet's Muralit, which is, you know, I guess it could be so little as cute, but, you know, you were working an uphill battle there. You had to first introduce people to it. It's hard to say. There was
生物多样性中心看中的第一种动物被称为冰川湾狼蛛。好吧，它是一只蜘蛛。这太恶心了。其次，事实证明，关于它是否是一个独立的物种还存在一些不确定性。所以那个被淘汰了。接下来，他们在阿拉斯加有一种被称为基蒂利茨斑海雀的小型斑驳海鸟，你知道的，我想它可能因为体型小而显得可爱，但是，你知道的，你在那里打的是一场硬仗。你首先得把人们介绍给它。这很难说。当时据我所知，
exactly one expert in the bird as far as I could tell. So these two species, even if you could make a strong scientific case, they're missing that wow factor. It wasn't going to inspire the public interest and the public concern that was going to make this petition go forward. So a spider wasn't going to do, a murillette wasn't going to do, no cave beetle is going to get the public upset. Where did they end up landing as their sort of animal that was going to help combat climate change. The polar bear. It's right there in front of you the whole time.
只有一位这种鸟类的专家。所以这两个物种，即使你能提出强有力的科学理由，它们也缺乏那种“惊艳”因素。它无法激起能够推动这份请愿书前进的公众兴趣和公众关注。所以蜘蛛不行，海雀不行，没有哪只洞穴甲虫能让公众感到不安。他们最终将什么动物作为他们将用来帮助对抗气候变化的候选者呢？北极熊。它一直都在你眼前。
They got the polar bear. I mean, fortunately, in 2004, I believe it was, luckily enough you had a really definitive first paper by a researcher named Andrew DeRocher linking climate change to the near future extinction of polar bears. Polar bears survive on sea ice for most of the year. That's where they live and they hunt seals
他们选择了北极熊。我的意思是，幸运的是，在 2004 年，我记得是那一年，很幸运有一篇由一位名叫安德鲁·德罗彻的研究人员撰写的极具决定性的第一篇论文，将气候变化与北极熊在不久的将来灭绝联系起来。北极熊一年中的大部分时间都在海冰上生存。那是它们生活的地方，它们在海冰上捕食海豹。
out on the sea ice. And as the sea ice broke up earlier and earlier in certain parts of the Arctic or sub-Arctic or just disappeared entirely from other places, you know, the entire platform where they walk around making their living was just going to be gone. I mean, like, if you're trying to decide if you are a Billy Possum or if you're a teddy bear, let's run the polar bear through the teddy bear test. Okay. So like, what are the things that it checks that make it appropriate to be the type of thing that we would rally around and love and want to make dolls of and hold? Yeah, I think it's operating on two levels. You know, a surface level, cute, brown face. You know, you can imagine it as a plush toy. It's no Glacier Bay Wolf Spider.
随着北极或亚北极某些部分的海冰越来越早地破裂，或者在其他地方完全消失，你知道的，它们四处走动谋生的整个平台就这样消失了。我的意思是，如果你在试着决定你是比利负鼠还是泰迪熊，让我们用泰迪熊测试来检验一下北极熊。好的。那么，它具备哪些条件，使它适合成为那种我们会团结在她周围、热爱它、想要为它制作玩偶并抱在怀里的动物呢？是的，我认为它在两个层面上发挥作用。表面层面上，可爱、棕色的脸。你知道的，你可以把它想象成一个毛绒玩具。它可不是冰川湾狼蛛。
And then on a deeper level, you have identical forces that were operating with the teddy bear story, where you have a creature that was regarded as this really powerful, independent lord of the Arctic. And now it's being shown in a completely new light as helpless, as dependent on us for help, as living in this world that is literally trickling out from underneath it because of things that we've done. Yeah. We have killed the polar bear off, and now we need to save the polar bear. Yeah. I mean, you know, I would read accounts of polar bears
然后在更深的层面上，你拥有与泰迪熊故事中相同的力量，你拥有这样一个生物，它曾被视为北极真正强大、独立的领主。现在它以一种全新、无助的形象出现，依赖我们的帮助才能生存，生活在这个世界里，由于我们所做的事情，它脚下的冰正在字面意义上一点点融化。是的。我们已经把北极熊逼到了绝境，现在我们需要拯救北极熊。是的。我的意思是，你知道的，我会读到历史上关于北极熊的记载，你会看到，你知道的，几百年前，比如北极探险家，他们写起这东西来就像它是个恶魔一样，你知道的，关于它的故事就像北极熊一样。我不知道这是否属实，但仅仅是这些故事会被复述，就说明了一些问题：北极熊跳进一个人的船里，试图把他们全都吃掉，甚至当那个人把熊点燃时也是如此。而你已经从那种形象转变成了登上《时代》周刊封面的那种形象，在那里它是一只悲伤、瘦弱的北极熊，走在一小条被水包围的冰带上，标题是：“担心吧，非常担心吧”。北极熊有科学依据，它有吸引公众的潜力。如果气候活动人士赢得他们的请愿，这将是一个具有里程碑意义的案例：第一种因为气候变化而被明确保护的物种。
from back in history, and you would see, you know, a few hundred years ago, like Arctic explorers, and they'd be writing about this thing like it was a demon, you know, stories about it's like a polar bear. I don't know if this is true, but it says something just that these stories would be recited, polar bear jumps into a guy's boat and tries to eat them all, even when he lights the bear on fire. And you've gone from that into something on the cover of time where it's this, you know, sad, thin polar bear walking on a strip of ice surrounded by water with the headline, Be Worried, Be Very Worried. The polar bear had the science, and it had the potential to capture the public. And if the climate activists won their petition, it would be a landmark case. the first species to be protected explicitly because of climate change.
公众似乎立刻做出了反应。在生物多样性中心和其他团体提交将北极熊列为濒危物种的请愿书的第二天，它立刻就上了 MSNBC 主页、CNN 的头条。它确实获得了你有一段时间没在濒危物种和气候变化报道中看到的那种关注度。一个电视广播称其为“绿色运动闪亮的白色象征”。我最喜欢的那期之一是《名利场》杂志的封面。
And right away, the public seemed to respond. The day after the Center for Biological Diversity and other groups filed this petition to get the polar bear listed as endangered, it was immediately splashed, you know, on the MSNBC homepage, on CNN. It really got a kind of coverage that you had not seen endangered species and climate change getting in a while. one TV broadcast called a shining white symbol of the green movement. And one of my favorites from this time is the Vanity Fair cover.
是的，当时德国动物园里有一只著名的北极熊幼崽叫克努特。他是一只可爱、耀眼、极具魅力的生物，他和另一位耀眼、极具魅力的生物莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥一起，由安妮·莱博维茨为《名利场》拍摄了照片。但公众关心的不仅仅是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。他们关心的是现在放在布什政府办公桌上的那份请愿书。这创造了当时的纪录，收到了有史以来发给政府的关于濒危物种请愿书最多的公众意见。他们收到了五十万封信件、明信片和留言。其中许多来自孩子们。
Yeah, so at this time there was a famous polar bear cub at a German zoo named Newt. He was adorable, flashy, charismatic creature, and he was paired with another flashy charismatic creature, Leonardo DiCaprio, and photographed by Annie Leibowitz for Vanity Fair. But the public didn't just care about Leonardo DiCaprio. They cared about the petition that was now on the Bush administration's desk. This set a record at the time for the most public comments ever sent to the government for Endangered Species Petition. They got half a million letters and postcards and messages. A lot of them were from kids.
你有诸如北极熊之类的画作。我发现了一幅北极熊快要淹死，同时又被龙虾和鲨鱼吃掉的画。你有信件说，奥克兰的一名四年级学生写道：“我觉得这对北极熊太不公平了。而且它们会淹死并灭绝。如果它们是你呢？”我很喜欢另一个来自一个叫弗里兹的孩子的信，他实际上提出了一个解决气候变化的方案。
You had drawings of like a polar bear. I found one of a polar bear that's drowning and then it's also being eaten simultaneously by a lobster and a shark. You had letters saying this fourth grader in Oakland wrote, I really think it is not fair to the polar bears. Also, they could drown and die off. And what if they were you? I liked another one from a kid named Fritz, who he actually proposes a solution to climate change.
他完全支持基于乙醇的解决方案。他说：“我对北极熊感到难过。我喜欢北极熊。每个人都可以用玉米汁来开汽车”——来自弗里兹。说得好，弗里兹。是的。弗里兹走在了他的时代前面。你知道的，就像我是在 80 年代长大的。
She's like all in on an ethanol-based solution. He says, I feel bad about the polar bears. I like polar bears. Everyone can use corn juice for cars from Fritz. Good point, Fritz. Yeah. Fritz was ahead of his time. You know, it's like I grew up in the 80s.
就像，就我对北极熊的思考程度而言，我思考北极熊的方式不像弗里兹那样，也不像写下北极熊溺水的那个人那样。是的。从那一刻起，它就是一个完全不同的生物了。这个计划正在起作用。而希望是，如果有这么多人关心北极熊，政治家们也必须关心。
Like, to the extent that I thought about polar bears, I did not think about polar bears the way Fritz does or the way, you know, the Juan who wrote about the polar bears drowning. Yeah. It's just a completely different creature at that point. The plan was working. And the hope was that if this many people cared about the polar bear, politicians would have to care too.
生物多样性中心的一位律师在谈到北极熊的文化力量时说了一句话，大意是“没有哪个政治家愿意对他们的选民说，是的，我投票赞成杀死北极熊”。政治家们对所有这些公众压力作出了怎样的反应？他们实际上真的能够设法摆脱它。因此，布什政府能够找到另一种程序上的漏洞。基本上，他们能够将北极熊列为受威胁物种，而不是濒危物种，
One of the attorneys for the Center for Biological Diversity was talking about the cultural power of the polar bear, bear and said something like, you know, no politician wants to tell their constituency, yes, I voted to kill the polar bear. And how did the politicians respond to all this public pressure? They were really actually able to wiggle out of it. So the Bush administration, they were able to find another kind of procedural loophole. Basically, they were able to list the polar bear as a threatened species rather than an endangered species,
然后他们可以对其实施一种名为“4D 例外”的政策。这基本上只是一种法律上的说法，即负责濒危物种的联邦政府部门没有权力或能力监管温室气体。因此我们现在不能真的将北极熊迎入我们要拯救的生物行列中。这意味着，当然，北极熊的生存可能会受到气候变化的威胁。但《濒危物种法案》无法强迫政府去做拯救北极熊所需要做的事情，而那将是监管温室气体。
and then they could apply something called a 4D exception to it. And basically that was just a legalistic way of saying that these arms of the federal government that are responsible for endangered species just didn't have the power or the ability to regulate greenhouse gases. And so we can't really welcome the polar bear in the ranks of creatures that we're going to save right now. Meaning, sure, the polar bear's existence might be threatened by climate change. But the Endangered Species Act can't force the government to do what it would take to save the polar bear, which would be regulating greenhouse gas.
当时的内政部长德克·坎普索恩（也就是监管濒危物种计划的人）在一次新闻发布会上表示，他不会让一项关于动物的法律被，引述一下，“滥用以制定全球变暖政策”。因此，这引发了一连串的其他诉讼，你知道的，关于濒危和受威胁之间的区别争论不休，生物多样性中心与布什政府之间，然后是奥巴马政府之间，来来回回，持续了多年，直到基本上，尽管有公众的强烈抗议，尽管公众对北极熊充满同情，整个问题最终还是在这个诉讼、反诉和语义反驳的迷宫中迷失了方向。让我感到震惊的是，你知道的，我们拥有气候变化的这个真正强大的象征，就像完美的泰迪熊候选人一样，你知道的，能让美国人关心与自然的关系，特别关心气候变化。而它仍然被智胜了。它失败了。我的意思是，你认为北极熊在这里无法胜任这项任务吗？
The Secretary of the Interior at the time, Derek Kempthorne, that's who oversees the endangered species program, said in a press conference that he wasn't going to let a law about animals be, quote, abused to make global warming policies. So this set off like a slew of other lawsuits and, you know, arguing about even the difference between endangered and threatened and back and forth and back and forth for years between the Center for Biological Diversity and the Bush administration and then the Obama administration until essentially, you know, despite the public outcry, despite the public sympathy for the polar bear, the entire issue just kind of got lost in this rabbit warren of lawsuits and counter lawsuits and semantic rebutting. It is striking to me that, you know, we have this really powerful symbol of climate change, like the perfect teddy bear candidate, you know, for getting Americans to care about the relationship with nature, declare about climate change in particular. And it still gets outmaneuvered. It fails. I mean, do you think that the polar bear wasn't up for the task here?
还是我们对北极熊的要求太多了？我认为重要的是回到那份濒危物种请愿书的最初意图。你知道的，最初的意图不一定是要为气候变化运动孕育一个吉祥物，来引领联邦政府以及一些根深蒂固且强大的企业利益集团
Or were we asking the polar bear to do too much? I think it's important to go back to the original intent. of that endangered species petition. You know, the original intent wasn't necessarily to birth a mascot for the climate change movement that would lead the federal government and some of the most entrenched and powerful corporate interests
还是说我们对北极熊的要求太高了？我认为回顾濒危物种请愿书的最初意图很重要。你知道，最初的意图不一定是为了孕育气候变化运动的吉祥物，从而引领联邦政府以及一些根深蒂固、权势滔天的企业利益集团
to suddenly change their way of doing business. The intent was simply to find a kind of legal backdoor with that first endangered species petition. You know, it wasn't part of the plan to have it on the cover of Vanity Fair, right, with Leonardo DiCaprio. But it was like the bear was just so damn charismatic that everyone just kind of lost their minds about it.
突然改变他们的商业运作方式。最初的意图只是通过那份濒危物种请愿书寻找一种合法的后门。你知道，登上《名利场》杂志封面并和莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥在一起并不是计划的一部分，对吧？但那只熊实在太有魅力了，以至于每个人都为之疯狂。
Also, the teddy bear phenomenon, it really didn't ask people to do too much. Like, people carried on with their sort of exploitation of the West and hunting. You know, maybe it wasn't done with quite such complete eradication agenda. But like, the teddy bear didn't ask much of us. That cartoon of Roosevelt in 1902, it takes 71 years from,
而且，泰迪熊现象其实并没有对人们提出太高的要求。比如，人们继续着他们对西部和狩猎的某种剥削。你知道，也许这种行动并没有伴随着那么彻底的灭绝计划。但是，泰迪熊对我们的要求并不多。1902年罗斯福的那幅漫画，从那个时刻算起到,
that moment to get the Endangered Species Act, which actually proposes a way to help that animal. So, you know, I'd like action on climate change that happen a lot faster, but I do think it's, we're letting a lot of power for people off the hook if we start to wonder, you know, what was wrong with the polar bear? I mean, dealing with climate change, I mean, we see it much more clearly now than I think we did in the early 2000s, right? There was this feeling back then that, you know, if we just got people to accept, accept it and care, we would just solve this thing.
通过《濒危物种法案》花了71年时间，该法案实际上提出了一种帮助该动物的方法。所以，你知道，我希望看到针对气候变化的行动能够快得多，但如果我们开始去想，北极熊到底出了什么问题，这就有点让握有权力的人逃脱责任了。我的意思是，应对气候变化，现在我们看得比2000年代初要清楚得多，对吧？当时有一种感觉，如果你能让人们接受它并在乎它，我们就能解决这个问题。
And I think that that's proven to be pretty naive. It's not just an environmental issue. It's, you know, a housing issue. It's a migration issue. It's an economic issue. It's a social justice issue. It's hard to just undo that just because enough people want to. So I think it's naive to think that the polar bearer could have, you know,
事实证明这种想法相当天真。这不仅仅是一个环境问题。它是一个住房问题，是一个移民问题，是一个经济问题，是一个社会正义问题。仅凭足够多的人的愿望是很难轻易扭转这一局面的。所以我认为，认为北极熊能够,
solved climate change. And therefore, I think it's naive to say that it was a failure because it didn't. One thing you can say for sure is that the polar bear got a lot of people to care about climate change who didn't before. It successfully became a symbol for an entire movement. But the problem with making any animal a symbol is that you can lose control of it. Climate change deniers started focusing on the polar bear too, using it to debunk the claims that it was in danger. Because there was a sense that if you could prove that polar bears were going to be okay, you were also just proving climate change. I talked to one researcher who was researching snow geese, and he made an argument in a scientific paper that, you know, this one population of polar bears, if there was no ice for them to live on for longer and longer periods of time of the year, they could probably subsist by eating snow goose eggs.
解决气候变化问题是天真的。因此，认为它没有做到这一点就是一种失败，这种说法同样是天真的。不过可以肯定的是，北极熊让许多原本不关心气候变化的人开始关心起来。它成功地成为了整个运动的象征。但把任何动物变成象征的问题在于，你可能会失去对它的控制。气候变化否定论者也开始关注北极熊，利用它来反驳它处于危险之中的说法。因为人们觉得，如果你能证明北极熊会安然无恙，你也就顺便证明了气候变化并不存在。我采访过一位研究雪雁的研究人员，他在一篇科学论文中提出，你知道，对于某一个北极熊种群来说，如果没有冰让他们生活的时间一年比一年长，他们可能可以通过吃雪雁蛋来维持生存。
And, you know, this poor guy suddenly was embraced by climate deniers, which he wasn't. And other polar bear scientists were upset with him, not as far as I could tell because his science was bad, but because he was. because he was sort of giving ammunition to the other side. So the symbol in some sense, you know, became the issue. Yeah. And we kind of lost sight of what it was all about. It's very dangerous, I think, when we start to mistake symbols for the whole reality. In a way, they're like these psychic pack animals.
然后，你知道，这个可怜的家伙突然受到了气候否定论者的拥护，而他本人并非如此。其他北极熊科学家对他感到不满，据我所知，并不是因为他的科学研究有多糟，而是因为他……因为他某种程度上是在给对方提供弹药。所以，在某种意义上，这个象征本身就变成了问题所在。是的。我们有点忽视了这一切的本质。我认为，当我们开始把象征误认为全部现实时，这是非常危险的。在某种程度上，它们就像是心理上的群居动物。
You know, we just heap a lot of our feelings onto their backs. And whatever we say about them, they just always have no comment. Do you think there's any hope for the possum to be something that we love, the way that they wanted us to love it back in the Billy Possum days? It's not too late, I guess. You know, maybe as we, as, you know, more and more creatures disappear, there will be a time in the future when people will think nostalgically about all the opossums that raided their trash cans and, you know, think of them as just,
你知道，我们将大量的情感倾注在它们身上。无论我们对它们说什么，它们总是无可奉告。你认为负鼠还有希望成为我们所热爱的东西吗？就像比利·负鼠时代人们希望我们去爱它们那样？我想现在还不算太晚。你知道，也许随着越来越多的生物消失，未来某一天，人们会怀念那些翻找垃圾桶的负鼠，并认为它们,
well, they were just trying to get by and now we owe it to them. And that's our show. Our expert of all things Billy Possum and the polar bear was journalist John Muella. He's the author of many books, including wild ones, a sometimes dismaying, weirdly reassuring story about looking at people looking at animals in America. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Brenda Dahldorf. Our other producers are Priscilla A LaBea and Ellie Lighthouse.
不过是在努力求生，而现在我们亏欠它们。这就是我们的节目。我们关于比利·负鼠和北极熊的一切事物的专家是记者约翰·穆埃拉。他是多本书的作者，其中包括《荒野者：一本关于观察美国人观察动物的有时令人沮丧、莫名令人安心的书》。《美国史与100件物品》是99% Invisible与BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持并策划。本期节目由布伦达·达尔多夫制作。我们的其他制作人是普里西拉·阿拉贝亚和艾莉·灯塔。
Foot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. percent of visible is part of the serious xM podcast family headquartered in beautiful uptown oakland california and bbc studios is headquartered in beautiful white city west london if you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider email us at 100 objects at 99 p i dot org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
脚。我们的助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。艾米·布拉肯负责事实核查。我们的主题曲由天鹅真实乐队创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯茜·2。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是香·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。斯特凡·劳伦斯负责美工。percent of visible是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心，BBC Studios总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系，或有物品让我们考虑，请发电子邮件至100 objects at 99 p i dot org。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。